من نافذه غرفه صغيره تراقب هبه شوارع
مدينه غاب عنها الامن والسلام منذ اسابيع
خرجت مع عائلتها الصغيره من منزلهم في
الخرطوم بعد انقطاع الماء والكهرباء جراء
القتال
لتستاجر العائله غرفه فوق سطح مبنى في
منطقه اخرى من العاصمه لعلها تجد فيها بعض
الامان وابسط اساسيات الحياه
[موسيقى]
لكن صوت ضربات المدفعيه والطيران والرصاص
كان مصاحبا لهم كيف لا وهذا هو الحال في
الخرطوم كلها منذ اندلاع الصراع
انا كل يوم بسمعها
مرعبه شديد يعني بخاف على ناس البيت بخاف
على نفسي
بتمتمات ودعوات تصلي والده هبه من اجل
ابنائها ومن اجل وطن غادره الامن
والاستقرار وعمت فيه الفوضى ولا يعرف ما
ينتظره
ان شاء الله ربنا يعني يدي العافيه والناس
تبقى كلها طيبه الوضع يرجع لوضع الطبيعي
ونرجع بيوتنا لانه طولنا بالجنه من بيوتنا
الكهرباء قاطعه لحد استي
الدعامه قاعدين قدام بيتنا ما دايرين يزح
وما راضيين ان نصلح العمود بتاع الكهرباء
طبعا الكهرباء ما في مويه ما في عشان كذا
احنا فرقنا من بيوت
قلقوا العائله الصغيره وخوفها ليس من وابل
القذائف والرصاص فحسب بل تخشى ايضا من
انقطاع الامدادات الغذائيه فلجات الى حياه
الكفاف ما في مواد غذائيه
كل الدكاكين مقفوله والموجوده باسعار
غاليه شديد بنحاول ناكل اكل قدره حق
الكفاف يعني بناكل وجبه عشان تكفينا باقي
المواد الموجوده لليوم اللي بعديه لان هم
معروف قصه من بين الاف القصص لاسر تكافح
في الخرطوم وتبحث عن ابسط حقوقها حق العيش
في سلم وسفينه وسلام وربنا يصلح الحال
ويرجع حال السودان احسن من اول بالكثير
ملوك الشيخ العربي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات